it's a millionaire theme our on the Dave
Ramsey show we're interviewing
millionaires so you know how they're
really made not how politicians left
wing nut jobs tell you they're made I
tell you how it happens in the real
world Fran and Greg is are with us in
Charlotte North Carolina hey guys how
are you hi Dave welcome welcome
what's your all's net weren't one point
three days cool and how old are you two
we're old 54 and I'm gonna be 57
tomorrow ancient ancient I'm telling you
55 and I'm feeling it this week so what
is this 1.3 invest it in give me the
breakdown Dave right now it's 50/50
because we're we're nearing retirement
sell 50% stocks and 50% bonds in cash
okay so like mutual funds or straight
stocks absolutely index funds for stocks
and bonds
okay so mutual funds in general all
right good and how much is it that is in
your house our house is about 230 so a
million seventy thousand is in stocks
and bonds and cash gotcha
and what was your average range of
income through your working lifetime mmm
that's a good question we were just
think about that before she's our
current salary household income is 130 I
would say we pay average oh do 7080 okay
all right and how much of this did you
inherit of your wealth well we wanted to
be honest we did inherit $100,000 but we
were already millionaires then and we it
was after my mom passed so we actually
just kept it safe and a savings account
to honor her and yeah for about a year
and then we just put it into our
investments you know we didn't we didn't
spend it we didn't blow it or buy
anything it basically you did not become
wealthy from an inheritance is another
little cushion gotcha
okay and what would have been your
careers well I'm a program manager by do
live database work and
I'm kind of the the data guy for my
region and I'm a program coordinator for
a non-profit it's a membership Society
and it's actually the job that I had in
New York I was able to keep it when we
relocated so okay yeah very cool and
what are your degrees in mmm I have a
master's in public administration
yeah I do too that's how we met we went
back to both for our masters when we
were quite a bit older than the norm and
that's where we met cool gotcha what
were your GPAs undergraduate about 2.6
2.7 and graduated about 3.5 3.6 guys do
better in graduate school cuz were grown
up yeah yeah so what about you friend
was your undergrad I think I was about
3.4 and then graduated about 3.7 it's a
smart one you know we had really good
teachers when I was in grade school I
credit them for all those reading and
arithmetic skills so how much of this
wealth is the result of you using
borrowed money to invest absolutely
nothing zero okay yeah and what part
does giving play in your all's financial
plan over all these years I do a little
better on that last year we gave about
seven percent so your business had a
little bit of a dilemma with some of
these larger organizations we've been
giving to when we read the stats about
how much overhead may have so we'd like
to find some local things to get to in
fact we were listening recently to one
of your guests who talked about
providing your your program in local
schools we like that idea
cool okay what's the most expensive pair
of jeans you ever bought Oh God maybe
thirty dollars I'm laughing because he
doesn't know we've got a cold with my
coupons in many hands with him and he
goes and waits in the car for me are you
still in any look at the price
that's a Kohl's it's not that expensive
all right so how many new cars did you
buy before you were millionaires never
bought a new car none okay all right
very cool and so your 25 year old
version of you too isn't listening to us
right now what do you tell them what's
the secret to being a millionaire
well big one is get out of debt get out
of debt spend less than you earn invest
and take advantage of the miracle of
compound interest so that 401k really
worked for y'all didn't it yeah I mean
we basically created this and about 10
to 12 years I want to admit one other
thing we had a bit of a jump start
selling our condo in New York in 2006
years we got it at the height you know
we were able to invest that money right
into a house you sold it a terrific time
didn't you yes so you guys have master's
degrees you're obviously well educated
on an average year how many non-fiction
books do you read I'm the nonfiction
rated here Dave odd probably about 20 at
least more I'd say if I looked at his
Amazon account which he shares with me
yeah we found his addiction it's on
Amazon that's a good addiction addiction
by the way we share everything we had
each other's passwords and everything so
he when I pay the bill sometimes you
know he wants me to look up something
and I'm like what was that 993 on Amazon
again again we do have a library you
know you were wearing me out over here
yeah I love it well he's a good reader
and it's obviously paid off for you guys
why you're great American heroes thanks
for changing for sharing your story with
America you just inspired a whole bunch
of people thank you you're the hero with
your weekend listeners for more than 10
years we love you thank you god bless
y'all hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind